prendre des otages civils dans un
magasin et venir dire que si les gir adc
sur le sentier des halles là c'est
aberrant pur amusement les traditions
religieuses y livre sacré c'est une
espèce de réserve de sens et les gens
quand ils sont en quête de sens pour
toutes sortes de raisons que ce soit
l'instabilité politique les problèmes
économiques mondiaux et ainsi de suite
à ce moment là quand les gens perdent
leurs références ils vont avoir tendance
à aller chercher des choses faciles qui
ont l'air à pouvoir exécuter
immédiatement et que ça leur donne une
raison de vivre et dans certains cas de
mourir aussi
on vit une situation qu'on aime pour
qu'elles ignoraient où n'importe quel
criminel va nous dire écoutez dieu m'a
dit tu l'aies alors moi je fais
exécutent leurs de dieu c'est qui qui a
donné la légitimité à ces messieurs la
dalle et faire ce qu'il a fait il n'a
aucune équipe n'a aucune légitimité pour
venir présenter la communauté musulmane
et surtout pas utiliser le coran d'une
façon malveillante de cette façon là
pour faire du mal à autrui et à l'huile
en russie la question à se poser c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui dans le corps et
des gens qui découpe une partie qui ne
retiennent que certains versets parfois
même dans des choses plus il ya
seulement une partie du verset il
s'arrête parce que si le verset 10 par
exemple s'ils arrêtent de combattre il
ne les arrêtés ou aussi alassane et
pointe rsa voir ça